The Joe Rogan Experience I can never do
what Chris Rock did with the live [__] I
would be [__] dead in the water the
live one's an interesting choice because
Louis did a similar thing Louie did it
live on his website and then he's gonna
release a full edited version of the set
and then I guess that's exactly what
Chris is doing he released it in the
full edited the [__] about Will Smith
was roots yes yeah
ruthless it's just like imagine you know
in life you play chess you move pieces
around you say I do this and the counter
would be that and like imagine the
thought like I'm just gonna slap Chris
Rock one of the greatest stand-up
comedians of all time it's not like he's
gonna tear my very vulnerable life apart
after I smack him with some of the best
comedy that anybody's ever written and
he's gonna hone it over a year before he
releases it yeah like what a terrible
unprovoked attack
what a dumb thing to do to do to like be
that person who's like publicly loved
you know like Will Smith was until that
moment I mean until that moment nobody
really had a bad thing to say about
maybe didn't like one movie or maybe you
thought the superhero movie was dumb or
but everybody loved that guy everybody
loves it I loved will I love will I
still love will but those two keep my
wife's name out your [__] mouth those
two are what sunk him if he just slapped
Chris Rock and then sat down and didn't
say anything people would think it was a
joke they wouldn't know what to do yeah
it would kind of drift off and people
would forget about it they would think
and they would say to Chris is that on
purpose did you guys plan that oh then
he would he would have skated
I'm so I'm not happy that it happened
but I'm happy the way it happened
because
when I was trying to explain to someone
who's not involved in Show Business how
bizarre the the industry is and how like
untethered those people are to either
morals or ethics or the just the reality
of human nature yeah they are completely
connected to the the Zeitgeist in terms
of what's popular and what's trendy and
what's accepted by our group and what's
rejected by our group that no one has I
mean not no one but in general the the
mindset of the people in Hollywood
there's no there's very little
independent thought it's all group think
so when Will Smith After smacking Chris
Rock and all that other craziness goes
on stage and wins the Academy Award and
gets a [__] standing ovation
that was like that's those people that's
that's this they don't know what to do
they don't have the ability to say hey
that's not right I don't care if you're
famous I don't care if you just won the
Oscar you can't assault people what you
did is ridiculous the way you're
behaving is crazy it didn't even make
sense it wasn't even proportionate to
what he said it wasn't like you you
overreacted in such a strange way I have
to wonder are you okay like what the
[__] is wrong with you yeah no one did
that they are like yes it was amazing
they went to the Vanity Fair party he
was dancing it was almost like it all
went away until the rest of the world
was like are you out of your [__]
mind what is wrong with you that is
crazy that that it did not get it did
not get acknowledged at all and then and
then I guess do you think that's a
testament to the internet Because the
Internet was like what the [__] yes it
definitely is a testament to the
internet because but the Internet is
just representative of most people
there's some people that thought that
Chris deserved it you know don't talk
about someone's wife there's a lot of
goofy people